[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALFRED SPECTOR:
I'm Alfred Spector.
I'm the CTO at Two Sigma.
And I'll be introducing the
talk and making some comments
at the end.
I have with me, doing most of
the presentation on the talk,
two of our engineers-- one in
our overall cloud engineering
team and one that is
focused on security
engineering in the cloud.
Focused on security
engineering is Nick Arvanitis--
Arvanitis.
He has been with us and
just done a tremendous job
facilitating the connection
between systems and security,
something that's
critical for all of us
as we move into the cloud.
And we are grateful
he joined us.
Jaques Clapauch has
been with Two Sigma--
I don't know-- about, what, two
years, two and a half years?
JAQUES CLAPAUCH: Yeah.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Two
and a half years.
With background in cloud and
systems at other companies,
and has also been
someone who's implemented
much of our security
controls and other strategies
in our cloud computing.
So they really know
what needs to happen,
and they've had experience
not just with Google, but very
broadly with cloud computing.
Before I start, I have one
very important message.
I understand your
seats fully recline.
So I have never given
a talk before where
seats fully recline.
So we will measure ourselves.
If everyone's seat is reclined
at the end of the talk,
we will not be invited back
to Google Next, I understand.
So try to stay at least
moderately vertical here
in this presentation.
All right, let me
just talk a little bit
about Two Sigma in this now.
So Two Sigma is a financial
firm and a tech firm both.
Broadly, our mission
is to get huge amounts
of useful, indicative
privacy-preserving financial
data, to draw
inferences from that,
and to optimize
economic outcomes.
We're certainly known
as a hedge fund,
but we do a lot more than that.
For example, we
are using data now
in a very rapidly growing
insurance operation, where
we're looking to greatly
almost revolutionize
the way that small
business insurance is done
to assist in capital formation
and reduce overheads,
et cetera.
Any case, we have very broad
and interesting challenges
in our space.
We collect almost a
petabyte of data a month.
So it's a fairly
large operation.
And to do this, we
feel that we need
to be a tech company as
well as a finance company.
And that's a complicated
balance to achieve.
We can't be at the
back end of technology,
as some finance companies
have traditionally been.
Otherwise, you won't
have the talent
to be at the leading
edge of our industry.
But if we adopt every new
tech thing without concerns,
we have $55 billion in
assets under management,
lots of regulatory
structures, and the like.
So we have to actually
be quite careful as well.
We're about 1,500
people, roughly speaking;
half engineering in the firm.
So it is really a
fascinating question.
In the security realm, I
think the hardest realm
of all in the space of
IT or computer science
is how to create an environment
that's incredibly flexible
and that has appropriate
levels of security.
One of the things we're
most concerned about--
not the only thing, but one of
them-- is the concern about,
how do we grow as a firm
without the risk of data loss
growing proportionally with
the number of employees
that we have?
And we want to do
that while still
having a lot of interaction
among our employees internally,
so without having to wall
them off from each other
and prevent sharing, without
having to wall them off
from new technology
or the internet,
to allow for this
fluid environment
where we can actually have sort
of our cake and eat it too.
And that's the really
interesting problem.
I suspect that's a problem
for many of you in this room.
And we're going to
be talking about part
of that in this
presentation today
as we talk about how to do
cloud computing in a way that
doesn't have a significant
risk of exfiltration.
One more comment to make--
we're really
interested in, how do
we make our whole ecosystem
more secure and vibrant?
That's why we're
giving the talk.
That's beneficial
to us, an I think
it's beneficial to
others in our industry
and, broadly, to cloud
computing and to Google as well.
So we're doing that
in the hope that we
can share best practices.
We're giving, I
think, four more talks
on security over
the next two days.
You can find them--
in fact, we'll
put up a slide at the
end on other talks
that we are either giving
or participating in.
We're also giving a
talk on serverless
distributed computing
in the cloud tomorrow.
And also, Jaques is
involved in giving a talk
on Halite, which is a
fascinating AI programming
competition.
We think it will be the
largest-term AI programming
competition yet, run in the
third incarnation this year.
And it explores very
interesting problems
not just about how to get
artificial intelligence
bots to do as well as people,
but to actually do things
that people could
never do before.
So self-driving cars,
they're interesting.
But we people do self--
we do cars pretty well.
We have to look at
problems that are harder
than what people can do,
certainly in the investment
management realm.
And Halite begins
to get at, what
can we start doing
with computers
that we can't even conceive
of doing as humans?
All right, without further
ado, let me turn this over now
to Nick, who will begin
the more specific parts
of the presentation.
NICHOLAS ARVANITIS:
Thank you, Alfred.
Alfred touched a little
on some of our challenges
and our threat model,
so I'm just briefly
going to recap some of
the key points there.
Those things really
drive the way
we think about security
and security controls.
I'm going to hand
it to Jaques to talk
about our evolution
and our journey
along the path in heading
into Google Cloud.
And then, I'm going to spend
quite a bit of time talking
about how we work
tightly with Google
to build native
security controls
and implement those controls,
and then finally wrap up
with a few lessons learned.
So a point that Alfred
underscored and I just
want to quickly reiterate
is that our attack surface
is very different to
what you'd imagine
for most organizations using
cloud computing resources.
We don't have anything
consumer-facing.
We don't have to be up
and exposed all the time
and worry about DDoS
and things like that.
Really what we're focused
on is internal use cases,
use of managed services,
processing data.
So we have a very sort of
inside out attack surface
compared to most organizations.
Alfred mentioned how key
intellectual property
is for us.
And really, when we think
about threat models and risk
mitigation, this
is the factor that
drives a lot of what we
put into as considerations.
And when we design controls,
we want to protect our IP.
Again, that's difficult
to do without hampering
people's workflows.
We don't want to take away
access to data or systems
or segment people
from each other
so that they can't collaborate.
So mitigating insider
risk is really difficult,
and one of the things
that's worth highlighting
is people talk
about insider risk.
And the immediate stretch is
we don't trust our people.
And that's not the case.
We definitely want a model
where one single person is not
in a position to completely
be able to exfiltrate
data or code, but that
also happens accidentally.
And if you've followed
the thread of how
sophisticated attackers
target organizations,
really what they're doing is
they're targeting individuals
with legitimate
access and then using
that compromised
individual's access
to move laterally,
access their data,
and ultimately
exfiltrate that data.
So when we think about insider
risk, we think about all
of those cases.
We're not just thinking
about malicious insiders.
And that's an important point.
Finally, we're not
beholden to many
of the regulatory considerations
that a lot of organizations
working in the cloud are.
We don't process
payment card data.
We don't necessarily have
PII or HIPAA considerations.
But we are very
strongly consistent
about what our compliance team
is interested in and mandating
that certain aspects
of our business
don't necessarily have access to
data that other businesses are
working on.
And this can even go a little
further in our research teams.
We're very cognizant
of researcher IP.
And in some cases, you
may have researchers
in the same team working
on the same data set
but not able to view the output
of each other's model code.
That's really important to us,
so we think about that as well
when we're designing controls.
So Jaques will talk a
little about our journey
into the cloud and some of
the challenges we faced.
JAQUES CLAPAUCH: So like
many of you, we had a dream.
And our dream was to connect
directly with the Cloud,
to have a truly elastic internal
infrastructure that extended
to an external infrastructure.
And for that, we, like many
of you, looked to Google.
Of course, unfortunately,
when we started,
Google was in its
humble beginnings,
and IAM wasn't
exactly everything
that we wanted it to be.
It was very primitive
and so much so
that they only gave us three
primitive IAM options--
owner, editor, and viewer.
And unfortunately,
that disallowed
us to go more broadly toward
the scope that we wanted.
And we wanted things
that were more granular.
There were things in each
of these that we desired
and things in them
that we didn't.
And we wanted
combinations of them.
So at that point,
because of that desire,
we were unable to
jump into that space.
And we decided to wait
a little bit until it
was a little bit more mature.
And when it started
getting more mature,
we finally reached
the point that we
felt was enough for us
to actually jump directly
into Google and be
kind of happy with what
we had with some changes
that we'd have to do.
And Google, as it
stood at that point,
actually had very,
very good services.
And it did everything
very, very well.
But it was, again,
in its beginnings.
And Google does this iterative
model really well in that--
you can think of it
in terms of a car,
if you're building a car.
You build really good wheels.
And then, you build a
really good steering wheel.
And then, you build the seats,
and then you build the chassis.
You don't just make a bad car.
You make very, very
good little parts,
and you put them together.
And we wanted in at
the beginning of that,
so we had to deal sometimes with
driving a car with just wheels.
So when we tried to make
our first connection,
we saw all these
amazing services
that, unfortunately, were
all directly connected
to the internet.
And we could use
them, and then we'd
have an open
gateway, which is not
what we desired if we're trying
to block exfiltration risks.
So we either opened up,
or we didn't use anything,
and we just had VMs everywhere,
which we could really
do without Google.
And that's not what we wanted.
On top of that, we didn't
really have a direct connection
to Google at that time.
Interconnect didn't
really exist.
We were in the
type of connection
that just went into
the Google fabric
but not into what we
wanted, into the projects.
And that inherently
meant that we
had to do something about that,
in which our case was more
to try to get a VPN
connection in there.
And that required a lot
of tuning from both sides.
And we didn't really
need the level of speeds
that most people need
when they're doing VPNs.
We needed much greater speeds.
Most people, when
they think about it,
are talking about megabits,
megabytes per second.
We are talking
about many gigabytes
per second connections.
And of course on
top of all of that,
Google had these nice
bonuses that were actually
really cool and really useful.
The first time, for
example, we saw Cloud SSH,
we were in love
with it, the idea
that we could just directly
connect to something.
And we didn't really care
that much at that point
of that specific exfiltration
risk, because at that point,
exfiltrations are
the speed of typing.
And you can do that in an email.
So that wasn't a problem.
Of course, problematically,
we found out
that there were extra features
that, again, a boon to many,
to us weren't that useful, such
as the Upload File Directly
button in the Cloud SSH.
Other things, such as
serial port connectivity--
serial port is an
amazing feature
if you have network problems.
You connect directly to Google.
You forego all of
your firewall rules.
You forego everything,
and you just connect.
It doesn't matter if
you have an external IP
or not, which, of course,
we didn't really want.
And it was either go
or no-go for that.
Service account is
another amazing feature
from Google-- also brought
about quite a number of risks.
They come with
refresh tokens that
didn't expire and could
be reached from anywhere
without any IP restriction.
And they were short
strings that you could just
write on a piece of
paper and take out.
And on top of that, there
was no egress firewall.
You could just send data
outside as much as you wanted.
And there were also a number of
overloaded calls at the time,
which, again, it's great.
It's Google magic.
It means that in very few
steps, you can do a lot.
But at the same time
for us, it means that we
lose some of our protection.
For instance, one
great example is
we had the IAM connection
directly through BigQ Select,
which--
BigQuery Select,
sorry-- BigQuery Select,
which also allows
you to export data.
So you either didn't
select things in BigQuery,
or you exported data.
It wasn't a clear
selection within them.
So how could we target all
of these things at once?
And for that, originally,
we proxied everything.
So everything we had to go
through these two proxies, one
which we called the provisioning
agent and the other one, which
we called Takoyaki.
The provisioning agent was
basically a strong precondition
checker with ordering logic.
So it was a direct
REST command that kind
of mapped to some of the
Google ones for things
that we trusted and we knew
wouldn't change over time.
And it held a very,
very privileged account
to do all those things
and to change projects.
And it only did things the
right way in the right order
such that in no step anything
could be ever compromised
if anything went wrong.
And if anything went
wrong, it did everything
backwards in the right order.
And it made sure that
no one called things
that they couldn't, such
as creating an image
with a serial port open in it.
Conversely, Takoyaki,
our other tool,
which is kind of just a big
joke, a big pun that we made.
Because originally,
it evolved from squid,
and Takoyaki is really squid
well-done, because it's fried.
It checked REST calls
for specific commands
and allowed us to
really be more--
allowed us to integrate
directly with gcloud,
because we could just
allow some commands
and deny other commands.
And it also injected the
tokens into the call so that we
couldn't--we didn't need to
worry about people just taking
them out, because they
didn't have access to them.
And of course,
both of those meant
that anytime
anything changed, we
needed to change
everything in our end.
Of course, Google was
awesome and upstreamed
a lot of the things
that we need to change.
But for a lot of
time, that was great.
On top of that,
just Google magic--
you asked for something, Google
goes proof, an it's solved.
So for things like the serial
port access, we talked to them,
and they made
changes that allowed
us to really just turn it off.
Or one other specific example--
we had what we call
the image exfiltration
hack at one specific point,
from one day to the other.
Again, Google went poof, and we
had this amazing feature that
actually allowed you to just
move images from one project
to another, which is
actually very useful
but, again, not
that much for us.
Because suddenly
that meant that we
could have a very locked
down project with images
with very, very strong
IP that it could just
copy anywhere and
then just exfiltrate
if that other project was open.
Again, Google went poof
again, and we had a button
that allowed us to turn it off.
And on top of
that, we had to add
a little bit of
our special touch,
so things like SAML, that
allowed us to connect directly
to our IDFS, which meant
that we could log in only
from our internal system there.
So really, it was protected
from external people.
Our OS was custom, so we removed
a lot of the Google SSH stuff
that could also
provide some risks.
For things like G Suite,
we added proxy headers
that only allowed us to go
to our own G Suite things
and disallowed exfiltration.
And we had our own proxy black
magic for everything else.
Of course, all of those
brought about some hardship
and struggle in the sense that
the VPN, as I said before,
was expensive, not just to
buy but also to maintain.
Any change, any
increase meant that we
had some very, very hard
communications with Google
to change everything.
We were doing a lot
of the application,
we we're doing a lot of work
that Google would end up
doing afterwards anyway.
And thankfully,
again, they upstreamed
a lot of what we did, so
it wasn't for nothing.
But they definitely
do it better than us.
So why should we do it?
And ultimately to ensure
that everything is correct,
we had to figure out all of
the undocumented endpoints
and all of the undocumented
IAM statements, which we still
recommend that you do,
but it's still a hardship.
And now, back to Nick for a
brief philosophical interlude.
NICHOLAS ARVANITIS:
Thank you, Jaques.
So the challenges that
we had were, in part,
driven, as Jaques
mentioned, by us
wanting to enable this
velocity and wanting
to enable people to harness
the power of the cloud
but also having very definite
security considerations
and security controls.
We did go into this eyes wide
open that we were iterating.
But as we were iterating,
we were racking up
a lot of tech debt.
And one of the
things that I believe
very philosophical that security
teams should do is to the quote
that Rich Smith gave when he
was the director of security
at Etsy.
Security teams really
should be enablers
for the rest of engineering
and for the business.
Any time security
becomes a blocker,
ultimately your
security posture will
suffer, because people will
find ways to route around you.
And also, you'll
lose credibility,
because you're no longer
a business enabler.
So the steps that we'd
taken, while there
were really great at getting us
into the cloud really quickly,
we fully understood that
we picked up this debt,
and we were causing
this kind of friction
for the rest of
our business teams.
And we really wanted a way
to resolve these issues
in a very cloud-native way.
It seemed like we were doing
things the old-fashioned way.
And this wasn't an ideal state
for us to iterate quickly
and to move faster.
So we sat around, and
we thought about how
we could address these issues.
And at this point, it
was really clear to us
that as a design
partner with Google,
a lot of the value for
us would be in surfacing
these issues to Google.
As a partner, we had to
surface our concerns,
and we had to talk to
them and understand
what was available for us
to address those concerns
or what was potentially
roadmapped so that we could
make the right decisions
around investing and mitigating
some of our risks
in the short term
or actually just holding
off, but making sure
that we weren't engineering
things that weren't going
to last and were just destroying
engineer productivity.
One of the things that
was also of value added
from our perspective to Google
is, as we heard this morning,
to paraphrase one from
Diane about Google's mission
statement, Google
exists to organize
the world's information and
make it easily accessible.
In our case, we really
wanted to do the opposite.
We wanted to organize
as much data as we could
but not make it accessible to
anyone outside of Two Sigma.
So this perspective, whilst
not unique to our industry,
was a little early for a lot of
the Google Cloud understanding,
because most of the
[INAUDIBLE] adopters
are consumer-facing
organizations.
The services are built
to enable somebody
to iterate really rapidly
and put things out there.
So we thought this
two-way conversation
would be really helpful in
terms of, as partners, us
informing each other and then
developing native controls.
So I'm going to talk a little
more in-depth about some
of these controls
and some of the ones
that are relevant to us and
the journey that we had.
And in this specific
use case, I just
want to point out that
obviously, security is
multiple layers in the stack.
So you have to be
concerned about application
security, host security.
Right now, I'm not going
to talk about any of those.
I'm just going to talk about
the cloud-native services
that we use to protect
the Google Cloud.
Likewise, Jaques
touched on G Suite.
I'm not going to talk
about that either,
because that could be
a whole talk by itself.
So the first control
that was really helpful
for us was organization
policies and still is today.
Many of the risk factors that
Jaques had talked about--
bringing up VM instances
with external IP addresses,
the serial console
access, things
like being able to configure
which of our projects
was the source of
truth for images that
could be used in other
projects because we were
using our own custom images.
And then conversely,
the flip side of that
is making sure that the
custom configurations
that we were baking
into our own images,
we didn't want those to
just be usable anyway.
So also being able to restrict
where those were used by policy
was important to us.
And of course another
important policy
is the fact that
we could configure
that only trusted user
principles from our domains
that we wanted to allow could be
added to any Google resources.
And organization
policies allowed
us to do all of these things
very powerfully, very minimal
work involved.
And we could configure them
at any level in the hierarchy,
from the organization
itself to specific folders
to actual individual
project levels.
And that gave us a lot of power.
As Alfred mentioned, I'm
talking a little more
about organization policies
and the specifics of what
we configured in a talk on
Thursday with the GCE team.
So we can go into a
lot more depth there.
But these are a really
powerful control,
and we evolved a few of
these together with Google.
And one of the lovely
things that happened
was all of the manual
things that Google
had to do for us
on the back end,
organization policies
eventually replaced those.
And they were completely
configurable and transparent
to us.
VPC Service Controls
is another huge one.
This one I really can't
understate the importance
of for our business.
In the context of this
talk, data exfiltration
is, again, our biggest
threat factor and our biggest
consideration.
And VPC Service Controls really
allowed us to really extend
the use case of the Google Cloud
in a safe manner, which allowed
us to then protect our data.
So VPC Service Controls as a
concept is an interesting one.
If you think about an analogy of
traditional systems and network
security, you can really
control your perimeter
in a Google Cloud VPC.
You have complete control over
how you set up the routes.
So as we do in many
of our projects,
you can just strip the
internet route entirely.
You can also control firewall
policies, both ingress
and egress now that
that's available to us.
What do you do with API access?
If you want to configure and
work with managed services,
which really is a lot of the
value of the Google Cloud--
things like Google Cloud
Storage, BigQuery--
being able to work with those
APIs but also protect your data
and make sure that
your data is contained,
that's a really
significant problem.
And it led to us having
very complicated workflows.
Again, in the spirit of not
wanting to block innovation
from one of our
teams, what we did was
we ended up having
an environment
that we created that was
completely standalone and not
connected back to
our internal network.
We had a very convoluted
path with which
the researchers and their
engineers and their team
were able to access
that environment.
And in there, they
had home servers
that they could then use to
access services like BigQuery,
GCS, Dataproc, Dataflow,
and access the internet.
The problem there was from
a security perspective,
we had to maintain two different
identities for these users.
One was their actual
identity that they
could use from within
Two Sigma, where
we had to do a ton of
research and engineering
and have proxies and all
sorts of other things
to ensure that that was a
read-only type role where
data couldn't be pushed out.
And then, we had to maintain
a separate role for them that
was tied to their home servers
with which they could use
these services with abandon.
And that's not ideal.
You have researchers
and engineers
with duplicated environments.
They're not comfortable
on their own servers.
They also couldn't do things
like work on external data sets
and then join those
with internal data sets
within Two Sigma and
really unlock the value
of research in that way.
So what VPC Service Controls
allowed us to do is now
we can unlock those workflows.
So at this point,
we have a situation
where we have an
environment configured
where a researcher
within Two Sigma
can work on their own
research environment
on their own servers,
their home servers.
And they can natively
access services
like Google Cloud
Storage and BigQuery.
And the power of that is
incredible in allowing
our researchers to
really use internal data
sets, external data,
and accelerate research
without producing massive
complicated infrastructure.
Again, there's a lot of nuance
to VPC Service Controls.
There's another talk that I'm
speaking in with that product
team on Thursday as well.
We will talk about
more of the mechanics
of the technical depth of it.
But this was a really key thing
where we worked very tightly
with Google.
The collaboration was huge.
It was conceived here a year
ago in some meetings Jaques
had over lunch with
Sam [INAUDIBLE]
and some of the
product team, and we've
collaborated really
closely over the last year
and seen the product evolve.
We used it extensively.
We pen tested it.
And we did a lot of research
on it as early-access adopters.
And really, we even
contributed to some
of the evolution, things like
bridging of zones, and some
of the more
complicated scenarios,
and representing our
own internal network
as a zone for VPC service
control, so a lot of depth
there.
But this is one of the
massive things that
unlocked a lot of velocity for
our business in a very, very
safe manner.
Jaques touched on our woes
with VPN connectivity.
Dedicated Interconnect
now really gives us
private dedicated connectivity
to the Google Cloud.
The bandwidth we have is huge.
And we no longer need to
tax our internet proxies.
We no longer need to maintain
really complicated policies
for a lot of use cases
on those proxies,
because the
connectivity is private.
And this coupled together
with the VPC service controls
and some of the other things
I talked about earlier really
has been instrumental
in creating
that environment
that's an extension
of our internal
network and the tools
that researchers
are comfortable with
and enabling us to
really accelerate
the use of the cloud
across our business.
Once we had that initial
use case proven out,
a lot of other business
units within the firm
are really now
interested in how they
can adopt these services using
this private connectivity.
So that was a big thing for us.
Finally, IAM
conditions-- again, this
is a very important element in
our overall security posture.
We believe very strongly in
defense in depth and layered
defenses.
And IAM conditions
really allow us
to complement the very
coarse-grained access control
that something like
VPC Service Controls
gives us with a very,
very fine-grained
and super granular
set of conditions
where we can meld
those together.
So right now, I can't
talk in too much depth
about IAM conditions, because
there's a talk on it tomorrow.
And some of the features
are going to beta tomorrow.
But if you do want
some depth, again,
please reach out to
the product team.
Chris Law, the product
manager, is fantastic.
What I can say is
that IAM conditions
allows us to now take
some of the principles
that VPC Service Controls give
us for things like controlling
where we want to allow
access to APIs from
and actually embed those
into IAM in some cases where
VPC Service Controls may
not be the right solution
or in cases where we want it
as an additional layer of depth
in our defense and depth stack.
So really powerful,
again, and really
helpful in terms of Google
listening to our concerns
and really building
solutions that enable these,
and allowing us to
adopt these early
and test them and help
with the iteration.
Those things are super valuable.
So again, over the
years, it's almost
been hammered into
security people
that no matter how much
you focus on prevention
and trying to keep bad
things from happening.
There's an adage that if you
think you're not compromised,
you've probably been
compromised for a while
and just don't realize it.
In terms of complementing
that security posture,
it's important to also
have detection and response
controls.
And Cloud Security
Command Center,
again, is a very cloud-native
product from Google
that allows us to have a single
console in a single interface
with which we can monitor the
security posture of our Google
Cloud.
Again, we were very
early adopters.
We worked very tightly with
Andy and his team about CSCC.
We helped it evolve.
One of my colleagues is
speaking on how we actually
use CSCC in terms of
monitoring our security
posture for the Cloud.
But again, a lot of
the security teams
that start to move
towards the cloud,
you see the kind
of mindset of, we
want to replicate
the security stack
and the security controls we
have on premise in the cloud.
And that's really the wrong
way to think about it.
The problems are
fundamentally different.
If you think about-- and anybody
here who's a user of the cloud,
you know that the scale of the
cloud and the pace of adoption
is huge compared to what
you have on premise.
And again, you'd be
creating tech debt.
You'd be creating
suboptimal solutions
by trying to bring
everything back in house
and put it in the same console.
And sure, there is
some value there
in having a single
pane of glass.
But really if you're
thinking cloud-natively,
you want to use
cloud-based solutions
to deal with the cloud.
And Cloud Security
Command Center
is a very strong
evolving technology
in that space, which we're
really excited about.
As a cousin to CSCC is
the open-source project,
Forseti, that Google sponsors.
Forseti's really well
used and contributed to
by companies like Spotify.
We contribute to it from
an open-source perspective.
It really is a
powerful tool for us,
because historically,
we had a model where
when we were making changes
in the Google Cloud,
we'd go through a very strong
upfront review process.
We'd review the code.
We'd review the implementation.
We'd go to deployment.
And then, things
would be deployed.
And who audits that
infrastructure?
Sure, we could audit it, but
we have multiple projects.
Auditing it manually
is less than ideal.
So this really
didn't scale for us.
What we wanted is--
again, thinking
in a cloud-native approach,
we wanted a perspective
where we could automate
our security posture.
We wanted to have
a place where we
could aggregate our inventory
at any given point in time
and then apply
security policy to that
and validate that our
assumptions are still upheld,
just in an automated fashion.
So we deployed for Forseti.
Forseti was really helpful
for us from that perspective.
And actually, a lot of
the work that we've done
is integrating Forseti so that
when Forseti fires an alert,
it will actually be viewable in
Cloud Security Command Center.
And again, we're using the
cloud to secure the cloud.
And you'll notice I didn't
talk at all about Stackdriver,
about logs and monitoring.
I think those are just a given.
We're just talking
about the next level
of monitoring in the cloud,
not the fundamentals.
So we've talked about
a lot of technologies
and a lot of tools that helped
us get to a decent security
posture.
But it's also important
to talk about process.
And I have a story that
Jaques will really--
it will resonate with Jaques
and with one of my colleagues,
Chris, in the audience.
The way that we did deployments
in the cloud, historically,
also evolved over time.
Back in the early
days, we had a couple
of people who had
org admin privileges.
And those were the
people who you went to
if you needed changes made.
And that was OK, and it helped
us iterate really quickly.
But again, thinking about
our fundamental security
principles, that
put us in a position
where if that person were
compromised by an attacker,
the keys to the kingdom
were right there,
and they could do
whatever they wanted.
So that was less than ideal.
So we took a step
back, and we thought
about how we could try
to mitigate that threat.
And we came up with v2.
And v2 was that nobody had
org admin privileges anymore.
We created one user principal
who was our super org admin,
and that user was used
for break glass changes.
And in terms of our
security posture,
changes that required anything
to do with storage or identity
and access management or
networking configurations,
anything that could open
up systems with data,
we considered those to
be break glass changes.
So what we did was
we'd have a workflow
where when somebody needed
one of these changes,
they'd submit the
change request to us.
The security team would review
the change and approve it.
And then what we'd
have to do is we'd
have to pair up with someone
in the public cloud engineering
team, because they had the
password to the super user
account, and we had the
corresponding security key.
And then, you had
separation of duties,
and you could make the change.
And that was fantastic for us
from a security perspective,
but from an agility
perspective, it wasn't great.
There were so many manual steps.
Ultimately, it culminated in
you having two resources, who
are all really busy.
And somebody was just
sitting around watching
somebody else type things
or click around, which
was really suboptimal.
So again, we took a
step back and thought
about how we could use
cloud-native technologies
in our own processes to
enable these workflows.
And what we netted out at
was doing a project together
with Jaques, again, where we
built a solution for automated
deployment.
We built this in a
manner that now when
somebody wants one
of those changes,
they'll merge Google Cloud
Deployment Manager template
code to a source control repo.
We'll review it and
approve it and merge it.
And that kicks off an
event-driven CI/CD pipeline
that will then have an
artifact ready to be deployed.
On the other side of
that, because the security
team doesn't know when
the optimal deployment
time is for an engineering
team, it doesn't automatically
deploy.
It's just ready to deploy.
And we have a UI that's
protected by Identity-Aware
Proxy that then allows
the user to log in
and then hit a button to
deploy the deployment.
They can roll back.
They can do all sorts of things.
Again, Google enabled us to do
this with their technologies
like IAP, like Cloud Functions,
like App Engine Flex--
really, really powerful
tooling and thinking
about things in a
Cloud-native way.
Finally, I won't harp on this
too much, but least privilege
is really critical to
us as a core tenet.
And again, Jaques had spoken
about where we started out
with just the owner,
editor, viewer.
Today, we don't use anything
but custom IAM roles.
So anytime somebody needs
to perform a workflow
or we have a new team that's
onboarding to the cloud,
we spend time to understand
what each specific role
within that business
needs to do their job,
and we craft an IAM role with
exactly the permissions that
are required for that
and give it to that team.
That allows us to
also share those roles
across multiple teams.
Again, I talked about
templates and source control.
That's really powerful for us.
And in the event that that
user were compromised,
we absolutely know what the
impact of that compromise
is based on what
their privileges are.
So again, customized IAM roles
went to beta a while back--
a really powerful
tool for us, even over
and above the curated roles
that Google now publishes.
So we talked a lot about very
specific controls, things
that we had to
address our problems.
Obviously, we only
had 50 minutes,
so there were a lot that
we couldn't get into.
But some of the quick
takeaways in terms of lessons
learned from our journey
and our process--
as if I haven't said
it enough in this talk,
it's really important to
collaborate with Google.
We work very tightly with our
account team, our business
manager, our [INAUDIBLE],,
our customer engineer
are fantastic.
But we also work really
closely with product managers
and with engineers.
And again, I can't tell
you how empowering it
is to be working on a product
and actually be on the phone
or in a Hangout with
the engineers that
are building that product.
That sort of level
of iteration really
is what enables quick velocity,
acceleration in the cloud.
That partnership is fundamental.
And again, Google also needs to
understand what your problems
are in order to resolve them.
And we've actually seen value
not only for our own firm
in some of the controls that
I talked about that evolved
through some of our issues,
but also, everybody else
gets the benefit from them.
So in the same way as it's
important to contribute
to open source, it's
important to work with vendors
and help them understand what
the problems are in order
to resolve those.
Sandboxing is interesting.
Again, thinking
about velocity, it's
really easy in an
organization like ours
with a security posture
that's really tight
to just stifle workflows by not
allowing people to do things.
But again, that's not
very cloud-native-like.
How do you enable people
to iterate and experiment
with the freedom that they need
but also maintain your security
posture?
The answer is difficult. So
the approach that we took
is segmenting out
development entirely.
So we have a separate G Suite
domain and a separate Google
Cloud Platform
organization linked
to that that's just not
accessible from within Two
Sigma.
You have to be on
our guest network
or on an unmanaged device
to access that environment.
And what that gives
us is the ability
to allow people the freedoms to
have the privileges that they
need to iterate and develop
and also protect our IP,
because we can't get
to our IP from there.
So that ultimately led to
even better workflows for us.
Because then when we have
a new team or a team that's
considering a new project,
they already really understand
what it is they need from
the Cloud Platform and IAM
and could just tell us that.
And we could easily review that,
approve it, and roll it out.
I talked a lot about
being cloud-native.
Again, there are obvious
security trade-offs here.
If you want the
ultimate set of control,
you'd build everything on top
of Google Cloud Engine VMs,
and then you maintain pretty
much as much as you want.
But there's a trade-off there.
Then, you have to worry
about administration.
You have to worry
about patching.
You have to worry about
vulnerability management.
The trade-off there is to use
completely managed services,
something like Dataproc,
where you don't have to worry
about any of those things.
But in turn, you lose that level
of transparency in the stack.
And it's difficult. There's
no right or wrong answer.
Every use case is
business-risk-dependent,
data-dependent.
But the key thing
as a security team
is to understand what
those trade-offs are
and present them to the business
so that the business can make
the appropriate decision based
on the value of the project
and the value of the data.
So again, cloud-native
controls--
really our posture is
wherever we can use something
that Google's built, they'll
support it, develop it,
and maintain it better
than any custom hacks
that we'd have to put in.
So that's our preference.
Layered defenses-- again, I
spoke about defense in depth
extensively, so I won't
spend too much time.
But you don't want
to be in a position
where a single
compromise or a mistake
or even a failure on
the cloud provider side
would lead to you
having a really bad day.
If you're one mistake
or one compromise
away from being on the
front page of the newspaper,
that's a bad place to be.
So the more that you
can layer defenses,
even if it takes more work,
even if it's unnecessary,
I like insurance.
We have an insurance business.
So I am in that space.
And the last takeaway from us
is it's important to move fast.
Again, a lot of
organizations that
are very security-sensitive
have a tendency
to take a lot of time in review
and, rightly so, the analysis
and getting in depth.
But again, you're blocking
the business's velocity.
And people are going to
find ways to work around you
if you take six months to
review one new service.
So find workflows.
And again, to borrow a quote
from somebody else, Jason Chan,
who is an engineering
director at Netflix,
he said, securities
job should be
to build guardrails, not gates.
So ultimately,
we're not there yet,
but my team's goal
is to enable--
none of our developers have to
think about security at all.
We could just build a platform.
We can work with our
partners, Google,
to build a platform
where developers can just
do their jobs without ever
having to think about security.
So on that, I'd like to
hand back over to Alfred
to wrap up with some final
thoughts and final notes.
ALFRED SPECTOR:
So I hope you got
from that sort of a
couple of thoughts.
One is we were pretty
early adopter in this.
And you heard about what we
did in that stage from Jaques
in his presentation.
When I got to Two Sigma
just about three years ago,
we effectively didn't use the
cloud for much of anything--
I don't know, maybe a
couple of tiny things.
And we were fairly able, because
of Jaques's and few others'
work, to get to
a situation where
maybe half of our compute
load was sort of on the cloud.
Although, we did it in ways
that were not as cloud-native
as we would like,
and we were not
able to fully use
all the services
that we knew that were coming.
As we got to the
second phase of this,
working more
closely with Google,
we were able to use standard
technologies after certainly
providing input as to
what they should be,
but able to use those.
And now, we've
gotten to that stage
where not only are we doing a
lot of compute in the cloud,
we're doing a lot more
heterogeneous computing
in the cloud using a lot
more different services.
And we do think that's
the future of all of this,
is that I don't think any
of us, unless maybe we're
Google or a very,
very large company,
can build all the things
that we will want to use.
They're just too big.
We can't build BigQuery
or something like that.
It's a huge project to go do.
So we're very excited
about the future.
We think that Google
now understands
a lot of these principles of--
that really come
from the notion that
ensuring that data
is not universally
accessible and useful, that's
not the only thing right.
You need to be able to
control that access.
And you need to be
able to control it
in a way, as Nick said very
eloquently, that you're not
one mistake or one
attack away from being
on the front page of
the "New York Times,"
as it has been said.
So we certainly don't--
we think that seems
to now be the case.
And we're very excited about
being able to rapidly move
forward on a lot more fronts.
These are the talks
that we're giving.
So on the security--
I guess it's already
kind of late on Tuesday.
So without a time
machine, you can't go back
to the earlier talks.
That, we do not have.
If we did, that would be quite
interesting in our business.
And on Wednesday
and Thursday, you'll
see the talks, though,
that are listed in security
and, as I mentioned, the
serverless computing talk.
The Halite talk, I think is
at the same time slot, right?
It's also at 4:35
in the afternoon
if you want to have
some fun and see
how maybe AI will continue
to be explored in ways
that are really challenging.
So we should open this
up to some questions
after the obligatory,
we're hiring.
We do exciting things,
as you can tell.
We're trying always to
be on the forefront.
More than any other
firm that we know of,
we get to answer the question
with all of the security
and computation, what is the
effect of machine learning
on AI in the entire world
of economic optimization?
No one knows the answer to
that question, in my opinion.
I've been in this field
leading research teams
for many decades.
We know small areas
where it's useful.
But we don't know the breadth.
So the firm is dedicated to
some really interesting problems
that, if solved, will make
economies in the world,
I think, far more efficient and
make our firm very successful.
So thank you very
much for your time.
Let's take some questions
if there are some.
[MUSIC PLAYING]